this is a production of Cornell
University so I spent time in Australia
and then in about 2000 went overseas
joined the international Set uh and then
went back to back to Australia in 2016
now I'm back in Colombia so I've been
around a lot so the title here and I'm a
specialist in Precision Agriculture and
and what you might call on Farm
experimentation and digital agriculture
but I've been around a lot and I've seen
a lot of demand for actually getting
change from research in agriculture so
this talk is going to be a real mish
mash there'll be some things that you're
very familiar with there'll be some
things that you probably don't like
there are going to be some things that
may be new to you but hopefully what I
want to do is just try and Forge Forge a
picture uh of change and how we can as
researchers we can get change and why
it's so important in agriculture culture
so here we are title delivering
agricultural research to Farmers
well is that gonna
go oh there we go very fancy I didn't do
that I didn't do that that was Microsoft
so uh delivering agricultural search to
Farmers should actually be delivering
agricultural research not just to but
also with farmers in actual fact seeing
Farmers not just as recipients of
research and of science but actual co-
innovators it's not easy but I think
it's worth trying and it's not the only
thing for science to do but I think it's
something that we've kind of kind of
ignored and need to develop a little bit
more so they outline a little bit small
there sorry about that but what I'll do
I'll first of all I'll just paint a
picture of the demand for uh science and
research I then talk not just about
production because we tend to Focus
quite a lot on production but I want to
switch just emphasis a little bit to
Food Systems because that's where we are
uh these days and then I just want to
spend a few minutes talking about how do
you know or what do you think science
really does how do you actually get
change in the system and how do you know
that it's actually occurred so I'll talk
a little bit about the theory of change
I'll then spend a little bit of time
talking about the value who actually
gets the value from research because we
hardly ever think about that and
actually it's a very under researched uh
uh topic and I'll just finish off with a
bit of stuff that I really like doing
theond Farm experimentation as an
example of putting farmers in the center
of change okay so that's the outline if
you want you can go to sleep for part of
it and then wake up for a bit of it or
maybe stay awake for the first part and
then doze off
later you okay it's okay that's fine so
let's think a bit about the growing
demands for a research I'm not from a
farm I will be get my own Farm but I'm
not from a farm or farming background
but even I can see that it's really
important globally uh agricultural
research to support change here we have
the obvious one to start with is
population growth population growth in
North
America up still growing through 2050
reaching a plateau about 2100
think about Europe Europe is already
passing its peak growth phase put these
two together you still got fairly
moderate growth of course if you think
about Latin America that's still in its
standard growth phase should flatten out
in the next few decades compare that
tiny compared to the growth of
population throughout Asia particularly
in India but not just India and still
still growing and not due to Peak for
another couple of decades now that's
worrying enough heading us towards uh n
plus billion people but here's the
really scary one for me is that the
growth of population in Africa projected
to increase through its
2100 and increase further still in fact
we'll only reach the global peak in
about 2018 so there's still a lot more
people uh heading our way uh and the
impacts are going to be
massive what are the impacts on food
demand well here's a graphic from the
FAO you'll all have read those reports
you know effectively a doubling of of
demand for food production and protein
throughout the world what's it going to
mean in terms of the demand for
land this is the business as usual
another 100 million hectares pretty
serious if we get it right if we get
agriculture really right then there's
some hope that will reduce the demand
for further extensification of
agricultural land by intensification and
other smart agriculture to actually end
up just a little bit more but that's not
happening just yet if we have this third
scenario which is called the stratified
they call it the stratified Society
scenario but it basically means that no
effort is put into correcting
inequalities throughout the world the
FAO project an actual fact that if we
don't fix that this is going to be the
demand for agricultural land arable land
anyway uh through to 20150 massive
increase much more than we can sustain
this shaded area here is the projections
of how much land will be
lost uh through degradation through not
taking care so huge demand for
improvement and efficiences of
agricultural systems and in terms of
investment in agricultural landscape
really major where's the food going to
come from well I just threw these in
just out of amusement basically these
are the uh figures from FAO for food
export for wheat millions of tons this
is North America okay you've had your
good years and your bad years but
generally it's slight upward Trend but
more or less stable this is Eastern
Europe so in other words you got new
entries into the global Food Market this
is for
wheat similar story for corn or maze
where you've got two new entries
actually overtaking this is Eastern
Europe again okay this is I guess the
Ukraine effect there but in actual fact
Latin America Argentina and Brazil are
going great guns to export more uh corn
throughout the world similar story for
soy here we have growth of soy exports
from North America increasing but those
from particularly from Brazil increasing
even more rapidly so it's going to be
change in production systems globally to
meet massive growth in
demand production isn't the only thing
that we need to worry about here we have
a grath of greenhouse gas emissions from
meat-based
systems two worrying Trends here huge
growth of greenhouse gases emission from
meat-based systems in Africa and Brazil
some places have actually got slightly
better China is one uh big problem there
greenhouse gas
management similar true for crops you
can have these graphs if you like rice
is obviously the one that people are
worried about but large growth in
greenhouse gas emissions CO2
equivalent uh throughout the world a
major concern
another concern food waste something
like 20 30% of food is actually wasted
throughout the food
system this figure here your country and
mine Australia and North
America
1,520 calories lost or wasted per person
per day huge losses within the
system major concern for the World Bank
so getting on top of that and another
problem facing agricultural research is
the protection of natural Capital
interesting to see McKenzie produced
this report last
year about getting companies on board to
try and correct the erosion of natural
Capital globally so my point is it's not
just production anymore there are a
number of different issues major issues
facing uh agriculture facing
agricultural research so you all know
all this but there's a switch to
thinking towards Food Systems food
system thinking offers a much wider
scope for opportunities for research and
change and now I'm about to show you
this diagram horrendously complex but
it's the best one I could find uh and it
portrays very well the complexity of the
food
system just to make this a little bit
easier to think about you can think
about five
domains this is where the business
really starts the production domain now
this has occupied a lot of our thinking
for many years how to produce more food
how to produce more stuff but in actual
fact when you take a food system
thinking there are other domains that
are equally important in actual fact I
got tuned into this when I looked into
digital agriculture try and to
understand what was happen Happ in
digital agriculture the investments in
digital agriculture there are more
investments in digital agriculture in
this end of the system than there are in
this end of the system so to them these
are the bit that's growing the consumer
side of things so it's not just about
producing more stuff and doing it better
but it's also learning what consumers
want and need and tuning the system
towards their needs a little bit more
there's a lot of attention also going
into processes improving these complex
food supply chains that actually get you
from a ton of maze through to the final
product that people pay a lot
for two more domains to think about one
is the capitals so thinking about how
can you protect a nurture human and
environmental capital on which the whole
system depends we tend to ignore that
but that's really important and
increasingly important throughout the
world and the fifth one is how you going
to govern the whole system how you going
to manage Finance how you going to
manage regulation to actually keep the
system working effectively and keeping
these demands in Balance so there's a
lot of thought gone into food system
thinking and I think it's opens many
different avenues for agricultural
research now here's the thing in reality
how does research actually deliver
change well there's one concept here
that I actually quite like a lot of
people in the CG don't like this they
think well we've done a lot of good work
developing new germ plasm we don't need
to worry too much about how our change
is actually occurring I think there's a
big difference if you're actually
producing new germ plasm you're
producing a wonderful seed you can throw
that seed into a system and there's a
reasonable chance if it's the right
thing that people will work out how to
use use it if you're actually looking
about how the system itself is being
managed that's a lot more complex issue
and you have to think or they have to
think people have to think a lot harder
about how the change is actually
occurring and we tend not to do that
we're so fixated on doing the work
writing up the papers publishing the
papers going on to the next paper that
there's no reward in most research
systems for actually thinking about the
actual change on the ground and this was
something that I really liked when I
first went to Australia the CEO of the
national research organization came out
and he said look you know I'm not really
interested how many papers you've
published this year he said he said
you've got to publish the papers because
that's how you learn your science but I
don't really care how many you've done
what I need you to do is I need you to
tell me what science have you developed
to enable change that I can report to
politicians and get the politicians off
my back so for me that was a revelation
because coming from the UK which was a
highly academic system and there was a
huge disconnect between research and and
real outcomes to go to a system where
research was being rewarded for its
science providing it delivered some kind
of change that was quite important so
again I think the theory of change is
quite a helpful
concept if you think about your search
Could you actually do uh do this the
theory of change could you actually
specify what is the the explicit or
testable model of how and why change
that you're supporting is actually going
to happen can you do that honestly it's
not easy uh and it can sometimes be
quite challenging and of course your
change may not be directly with Farmers
you might be helping somebody else who's
going to be helping Farmers you're an
important part of the chain but still
you're in part of what's called an
impact pathway which is an important
concept
the theory of change also needs to
identify the context and the key actors
in the system so who actually are you
talking to who are you hoping to change
what are their behaviors that you're
expecting to change and have you really
thought about it or whether you're
delivering what they're what's going to
enable them to change and then think
about the causal Pathways a little
bit that can contribute to those
outcomes and impacts now not everybody
in this room needs to worry about all of
these but you're part of a change
process and it's good just to recognize
uh what part you play so here you have a
theory of change diagram you know you
thought my diagrams were terrible this
is even worse but it puts all of the
things together this is what we tend to
focus on as researchers activities and
if you're lucky we'll think a bit about
the outputs you know what we're
producing where are our results where
are our papers or reports but the
process actually goes through towards an
outcome which is basically a behavioral
change somebody's going to do something
differently that they couldn't have done
if you hadn't delivered that
output what is that and how is it
actually going to happen now here they
talk about these things spheres of
control spheres of influence and spheres
of interest you can only control this
part of the change process but you're
assuming and you're understanding and
because you talk to people who you hope
are going to use your research you're
going to help deliver these in the
sphere of influence and over the longer
term produce these bigger term impacts
that you think are really really
important actually just going through
this process is very important very
helpful too because it actually helps
you sharpen your activities and outputs
to actually achieve these
goals okay I don't want to spend too
much longer on that because it's kind of
bureaucratic
um but I think it's helpful and if I was
a young researcher I would really like
to have learned a little bit about that
so even if I focused on my bit I could
see where it led towards the bigger
picture
okay now here's this bit of weird stuff
here is it the value of the change
drives research but who actually gets
the value often we make assumptions
about
this and I got into this because when I
looked at digital
agriculture it pretty clear that there
was a lot of work and a lot of
activities going on in digital
agriculture but Farmers didn't get it
they didn't like it there was a article
in the Wall Street Journal Harold you
might seen this one it was a couple of
years back about the disappointment of
big data in agriculture and about
disappointment of digital agriculture
basically everybody's still trying to
figure out where the value in data is
this is a this was a speaking and it a a
feature in the Wall Street Journal and
the reason this came up is because
agriculture here we had a a a graphic of
the different sectors of the US economy
and don't worry the Australians were
just as bad this was the level of
digitization within the sector
agriculture bottom of the class
basically so the question is why is that
actually occurring and it seems to be
the problem is that the value isn't
being delivered to
Farmers now how to explain that now this
isn't the prettiest of diagrams but I
hope it gets somewhere the best I found
to try and help explain this was uh from
a uh series of work in the UK by an
economist called pavit and he
identified uh how technology was
used in Industries in the UK and he came
up with this four class
model that explained where the value was
created and more importantly where it
was kept he had these four classes and
here these flashes are supposed to be
Valu don't worry I'll explain these
hopefully in a second let's take this
one because this one is the one that
we're probably most familiar with this
is I think he called it the public uh
R&D model
whereby governments invest in the
research they do that because they're
expecting that you will
produce brilliant research outputs that
have some public good they don't mind
you actually working for senta or or
somebody else providing you do it at
Al's length because they're saying we
want to use taxpayers money uh to try
and develop things that has a general uh
general public good now what you might
find a mixture of innovation hubs to try
and help this process move
along and in
agriculture traditionally what we' tried
to do is rely an extension processes to
get from here down to here these farmer
groups okay so the value is created here
and it's actually shared
uh and often promulgated by publication
processes to actually try and spread the
word that's
good now the next model relies on
private
R&D John Deere
senta buer they have big research
budgets good
operators they're not going to publish
their or spread their intellectual
property any further than they have to
so they try to tend to keep it because
that's where where they're getting their
value from they have a product that they
want to sell to Farmers or others they
want to sell the next product they want
to get more value out of the next
product out of their R&D by providing
something that is considered to be worth
a little bit more so they keep the IP
they keep the value in house different
to the one before they actually try and
keep that in house and quite often
they'll protect that quite fiercely and
if you see where the investment is going
in digital act you a lot of it is
actually going into this kind of thing
whereby a service or a product is
actually being delivered to Farmers
farmers buy
it lot of the value stays with the
producer the third type is what you
might call scale sensitive it's what
it's not a great word but what it means
is that the value is generated at
different parts of a supply chain or a
value chain economists can't work out
whether they prefer that now you can
think about this there are large
integrated organizations within the food
system remember the food system diagram
there are some large organizations
within that that they don't
want um disruptive innovation they want
cumulative Innovation they see their
position in within the system as being
quite powerful and dominant and they
want to try and hold that within their
within their organizations as much as
they can so they will protect that uh IP
as well they'll have closed doors they
they they won't willingly share all of
that they'll they'll expect that to be
within their own system so you can think
of the the large agricultural Agri
business organizations that actually use
technology learn and keep it that way
but farmers in these cases at best are
seen as suppliers of product and might
get rewarded for it or they might not
but they're not getting value so that
leaves us with the last type of
model which is what's called supplier
dominated not a great word but basically
this is the one I would say is
missing somewhat and so what I'd like to
think of and like I'd try and see is
actually improving the value generation
within this class of business model in
which Farmers learn by doing they much
more but also increase the value that
they can generate through networking and
through technology adoption so obviously
that is going to rely also on these so
the interaction between these and
particularly from you guys how do you
actually get the processes through to
that so they can start generating their
value for themselves uh near to
hand that's where we come on to unarm
experimentation and I'll just spend just
a few minutes on this in which we see as
probably you do farmers as co-
innovators not receivers of innovation
but actually co- innovators okay now
when you say the word experimentation it
raises all kinds of things in research
institutes such as this one so you can
think about what is an
experiment and often we use experiments
to explore law theories but I would say
there is different types of experiments
and different types of experimental
thinking one is around epistemic Theory
driven which tends to be have a semantic
Focus that means that you're interested
in the meaning that the results
represent to you and to do that you need
to have the theory and these are
scientist implemented because that's
what we do you know that's what we learn
as scientists but there's another type
of experiment which is action guiding
Theory it's much more pragmatic you know
if you talk to a farmer about the
results of an experiment that they put
in they're less interested in actually
why it occurred they do want to know why
it occurred but they're less interested
in why it occurred that the fact that it
did occur and that it means something to
them in that system you could say that
they're sort of characterized pain I
don't really care why it did it I just
know it does it every year and I want to
fix it you know so that's much a
stronger uh action it's much more
pragmatic action and it's user
implemented now what I'd say is that in
agriculture we actually might have taken
a wrong turning because experimentation
was the core of agricultural development
for a long time but in the 1920s you
know sir Ronald he came out with his
fantastic analysis of variance you know
mathematically uh
mathematically um elegant thinking and
the learning at that time definitely
switched switched strongly to
Specialists then we moved
into uh sort of a a style of working
with a lot of gen germplasm research and
then Precision egg came along but it was
driven from here or the weat the corn
Bel anyway and learning and IP tended to
be distanced somewhat from Farmers
Farmers again were pushed into the
position of being buyers of intellectual
products and services that were
developed by others so what we're trying
to do with the of here pharmac Centric
ofc of is actually trying to shift the
emphasis back to Farmers so this is what
it looks like you got a diff two
different types of change processes here
we got the exogenous one that we've
tended to use for a long time you're
aiming for certain generalizable results
you don't really know too much about the
relevance because tend we tend not to
ask we don't know about the adoption
rate and are often disappointed that
there should be more but it hasn't
happened and it generally has a low data
content because the experiment is where
the data was generated when you put it
out you don't tend to follow
up endogenous approach we want to see
pharmac Centric Farmers come up with the
questions
the results are often highly variable in
our experience they're often highly
variable and quite uncertain but they're
extremely relevant on site and they're
easily adopted because they're framed by
the farmer and they're interpreted with
the farmer in ways that they can use and
they tend to create a lot of
data now here's one that we started with
this picture it's a terrible picture I'd
actually lost track of it completely but
this was the first of our large uh on
Farm experimentations it was in the
bloody 90s right it was 30 years ago
almost and it was done almost by
accident we had a a farmer a farmer's
boy who was brilliant at the technology
and he actually developed the first
veril technology in Australia to produce
this
checkerboard uh uh test and we thought
this was just fantastic the farmer loved
it agronomists hated it
uh because when we analyze the results
of this experiment and it was a 7 our
first experiment 72 hectares right we
found that there were many different
sources of variation we had set this out
as a nitrogen trial but in actual fact
there were weeds there there was wetness
there was drought on the all in the same
area there was uh potassium deficiency
over one part and another part the trace
element deficiency we said to the farmer
you know sorry Doug this is this is
impossible you know how can we how can
we make sense of this there's just too
many things going on in actual fact
nitrogen even though we' plasted it with
soil samples and had a really good
agronomist working with us we still were
unable to explain much more than about
30% of the area the response over 30% of
the area and the farm said well welcome
to my world you know this is what I have
to deal with every padic every year it's
uncertain and this information even
though it covers only part of the area
it's still useful to me I find it useful
and I believe it because it's on my land
anyway we thought this was great but
actually fact it wasn't the first of uh
pharmac Centric attempts but these a lot
of work would been going on in the 80s
and 90s uh Larry Harrington he was here
do do you remember Larry he was he did a
lot of this earlier work with simmit and
seat Jackie Ashby they did a lot of
participatory research but they didn't
have the data that we have now and they
didn't have the processes and they
weren't able to capture the value put
back into the system so that's what
we're aiming for so anyway we uh we got
on to this and we did all sorts of weird
stuff o sorry uh it's gone we had uh
strips replicated strips blocks donut
Checkers all sorts of experimental
design the Farms liked all of them uh in
many cases the agronomist found it very
difficult to work with because the
results were too big too uncertain so
what's the basic process well the first
one is you need
organization you need to organize F you
can't can't do with one to one you got
to look for organizing
entities uh in our area it was farmer
groups or it could have been a supplier
these sort of things the organization is
key farmers do the inquiry they start
looking to see what happens if I do this
The Specialist support let me help you
with this stuff and and then the farmers
and Specialists together interpret the
results and then they continue inquiry
very simple process as I said we had
lots of different types of uh designs
this was actually one of our earliest
ones we were very proud of that but
nobody else liked it um checkerboard and
strips Farms do these in Australia they
in in I know here they do they do a lot
of these standard this was actually the
largest one we we did was 6,000 hectares
but that was an oil palm they just
wanted know what was going on the enre
Strip or the strip trials those are very
commonly used experiments quite large
and the important thing about that is
that we see it as a continuous what we
call a racetrack process of Engagement
data capture analysis interpretation and
then use so there's a mixture of
Technical and social processes going on
here we have some basic rules that we
applied we found them useful the first
was obviously keep it pharmac Centric
this was one that the farmer more or
less put in without help he just wanted
to do it
himself keep it simple keep the
experimental structure simple because
the landscape is big and it will get
complex so keep the experimental design
as simple as you possibly can keep it
big two reasons for that one is that you
want to use as far as possible
commercial Machinery uh you want the
farmer to be able to install the
experiment without thinking too much
about it it's got to be concordant with
their ways of managing it the other
reason is that farmers understand and
manage their land according to landscape
Clues and signals they understood for
example that this bit of dirt down here
produced these results for that reason
and that this was quite different up
there in other words they like it big uh
because it helps them interpret it and
apply it to management keep out of the
way there are times when Farmers don't
want to talk to you there are times when
they're too busy so it's there are
certain times when we had this rule keep
out of the way make it easy and keep
exploring okay so those were basic
ideas so how do you actually get value
from the process well here we have a
number of kind of quotes about what are
the sort of
things uh that they found and there are
a number of characteristics about the
way that farmers said they found these
results
helpful one of them is that it was
pretty clear what worked to them and
what didn't what was important
accumulative one is when it helps them
learn much more about their system and
they become more certain to the point at
which they can make those critical
management change and the other one is
that sharing can be important that
actually a collective use of insight can
be really important okay just a couple
of minutes to
go how do you actually scale up the
whole process well I don't know how many
how many of you might be familiar with
this but we use the business model
canvas uh idea to actually couple the
idea basically what the business model
canvas approach does and and we might
think we're proud if we get a few
hundred or even a thousand citations
this has actually got over 20 20 22,000
I think so is a very widely used in the
business world uh concept of basically
putting the whole package together
concentrate on these two bits first is
what's the basic idea how are you going
to offer a new service or what are you
going to produce that's going to help
people and who actually will you benefit
is it going to be Farmers is it going to
be certain types of farms is it going to
be Consultants may maybe suppliers if
you haven't worked out that then you
can't work out what this whole business
model is doing if you can work that out
then you can actually develop a business
model that can be scaled up and then so
the final part of this of story is
actually networking as Janice you'd
recognize some of these places probably
with horror but there we go so but they
this was just our first attempt at this
after doing that but there was an
instantly a a network of people who are
interested in trying to develop this and
that's really important from uh from a
scaling up point of view because you
can't be talking to individual Farmers
you need to actually scale out the
business model for impact so in summary
what have I been talking about first of
all hopefully made it pretty clear that
agriculture has to get more active and
there are still some really major uh
problems facing us and research it's
really a good time to be in agricultural
research as I think there's an awful lot
to do but I do think it's it's valuable
and important to think a bit not just
about production but think about the
food systems and think about the places
within the food system you might like
the research you're doing to actually
impact and change
things I would say farmers are often not
the only or
even most common uh developers of
research insight as currently done and
they are not often the recipients of
value according to those four business
models they there hasn't been that value
generated with Farmers for them they
tend to
be treated or assumed to be as customers
or clients of valuable IP generated from
elsewhere I think Cornell might be
somewhat different in that it still and
it always had an extension mindset of
government fund funded change but still
still good to focus on how the value is
going to be generated and how farmers
are going to get it and so what I'm
saying and what I'm working on
personally and with Louie is actually
pharmac Centric
co-innovation uh with
networking to develop this value based
IP with farmers and actually networking
up and I'd say here there's a huge new
role for researchers but it's not just
agronomy you've actually got to have
some social sciences in there and you'll
have the data Sciences to me and that's
very rare to find in any University
combination of agricultural Sciences
social sciences and data Sciences but
there's going to be a mix of those in
there to actually really get on top of
this because I think the real goal too
is that you want Farmers to go digital
and I think that's where the opportunity
is going to be so those words digital
dir word digital is a good word thank
you very much indeed thank
you the floor is open I will look here
question is there any pach left first
question
y I
wonder for
the Deale of the Innovation the
connection to markets Etc exactly yeah
good question yeah when you think of it
commodity Crop Production well can treat
Farmers as basically like surf producers
somewh because if you can't generate
value at the point of production then uh
the per unit value at the point of
production is relatively small and there
you see a lot of the value in
digitization anyway in the commodities
is actually taken by that second class
of the integrated uh the integrated
supply chain operator they they get the
value from that there they actually want
to drive down the price of commodity the
mo the most they can and they're happy
to receive product from wherever they
can if you think about high quality or
high value production there's much more
scope for Value generation around
Farmers I mean I live in Colombia the
the
only uh sustainable part of Colombian AG
culture is high quality coffee and it's
quite interesting it's actually a very
high skill level needed to produce
quality coffee and incidentally it was
the only area that was never governed by
Gera they always organized themselves
because they had very strong Social
Capital but it's an example of yes the
higher the value of the product and in
New York you have certain high value
products that are really important I
think and then you have a strong
connection with customer base down the
right hand side of the the food system
and you can produce more value by
learning what the customer wants and
actually learning how to produce it so
yeah good question but that's that's
right thank you very much
for um I You' mentioned farming systems
research to me like fsrd which started
in the 70s late 70s you know these
Concepts have been around for plus 40
years right ver beta what you presented
here yeah you suggested that one point
of failure might have been lack of data
to to work at that scale I'm I'm not
sure that's that's the entire
explanation I just wondering if you had
other thoughts no I also mentioned I
don't think they looked at the value
proposition idea and that's a kind of A
New Concept to try and work out well how
is what is the CH what is the
fundamental change that's going to
create the value and how you're actually
going to produce that to actually go
through that process you need to get
through to this business model concept
that is probably well it it postdates
the earlier farming system research so
from the farming system research stuff
that I saw I thought well this is great
but it was always dependent on external
money it was always the projects and
once the project money ran out then you
know it was CH Farmers we nice working
with you but we can't come back here
anymore I thought when I saw that we
have to get beyond that we have to try
and work out a way in which either
Farmers themselves or suppliers or
buyers are actually prepared to
subsidize or invest in that process that
involves the farmers and is around the
farmers and I don't think we really
understand I don't think we really
understood how to do that until we
thought about the business model
thinking so yeah well spotted and and I
agree you know we we thought we were
fantastic doing this Farm research and
then I came across all this stuff that
Larry had done 20 30 years earlier that
we would were talking about the 90s and
also in cat they did a lot of work on
that and they're still trying to do that
but they hadn't got over this these two
fundamental barriers one was the the
data because without data you can't it's
got to be cheap data because you have to
have a a an easy process a
cost-efficient process if you like for
the farmer to actually provide Insight
if you ask farmers to go out and even
you know measure on on yield Cuts what
they often they won't do it it's too
much it's too much work or they might
not just they just might not have time
to do it so you've got to have easy keep
data to do it so in our case we were
using Precision EG technology because
every Harvester comes with that
technology built into it these days
we're looking at remote sensing to
provide a backup for cheap data so you
can guarantee a process can run but you
also need the second part which is the
business model which actually identifies
the value and actually works out how
it's all going to work so thanks good
question um just a question kind of your
thoughts um in terms of thinking about
more developed countries and and less
developed countries or often kind of the
global North and Global South and the
data collection in these different um
areas let's say thinking like in the US
here we have a really great land grant
system and extension system where there
is a lot of on Farm research and and
hopefully unbiased science griven on
Farm research here you tend to go into
develop there's a lot more on Farm
research but may
from private companies right Magenta Bay
that and kind of the bias around the
data collection in these different areas
I don't know any thoughts on that and
how that may drive farmer decisions in
those areas they okay there's there's a
lot of work in Africa around um farma
groups which because the one of the key
things that you need is you need that
organization to actually make the enable
the process to run and so that's there
is a lot of attention to farming groups
and they're very interested in this
process as a means of farmers generating
their own Insight um there is you need
the cheap you know the cheap data you
need that cheap data and you can get
data but it's but it's not that easy
that's why we're looking at uh imagery
remote sensing to actually provide that
imagery the question about how do you
trust how would you trust the results
from uh would you trust the results from
buer I think well they have the biggest
uh incentive to actually work with
farmers and those that I've spoke to
they're quite Keen to do that farmers
aren't stupid they they're happy to work
with by but there you know there has to
be a clear Arrangement it was quite
interesting when we were working with a
fertilizer company in
Australia and the fertilizer company was
rolling out their program of on Farm
experimentation with their clients and I
said to the guy who is running it for
the fertilizer company I said but you
realize um you realize that farmers
might use these results to buy less
fertilizer not more you know you realize
that I need to tell you that right now
because they might see that half of
their land just isn't responding at all
so they'll buy much less than they did
before his response was really
interesting he said he said I don't care
I don't mind that he said our main game
is to establish trust with the buyer
because we don't want to lose our
clients and then have to try and find
them again he say as far as we're
concerned we we're prepared to take a
reduction in volume if we have them as a
client throughout time so that sort of
really caught my attention because what
that meant was that the trust between
the the the buyer and the seller or the
the supplier and the farm user at the
moment throughout Africa well Harold you
you know this is that the at the moment
fertilizer is shipped out shipped into
country distributed and then from then
on most suppliers have no idea what it
does uh they don't even know where it
went half the time if we could change
that kind of model to one in which the
supplier has a much more vested interest
to actually enable Farmers to use it
better through this farmer Centric
process that that's what we're aiming
for so yeah the balance thing trust
thing is a big thing very good good
question tricky one tricky one but a
good one yes um is it
often are other Ines usually provided uh
to the farmers to participate in the
research or is it usually enough the
value that they might get all learning
from the
experience I think there are cases where
that is done where Farmers have to be
persuaded we didn't find that virtually
every farmer I've spoken to is Keen to
do it because they they like to do it
anyway but remember that the fiber you
have to be careful about the rules you
can't come in and say you're going to do
this you have to come in and ask the
questions and what are you interested in
changing and then when you're designing
the experiment it has to be easy for
them to install so you hear about a lot
or you read a lot of Publications talk
about some of the on Farm
experimentations that we but they're too
complex to survive outside the research
ground so you you have to design it in
that way but I've never found difficulty
in in uh getting Farmers to to trial
providing you do that good
question the um
so I I uh a couple days ago I taught a
class for our freshman sustainable
ulture for our first semester freshman
and um about 10 minutes in it was about
digital
Ag and about 10 minutes in uh the
students asked a number of very
insightful questions like about that de
just
asked but it was also a question about
well what about the public Pur private
sector right so it's great to do all the
on Farm research right but ultimately it
needs to the the information that you
gather and the knowledge that you
develop needs to be delivered on a
continuing basis right there need to be
Services provide it needs to go into a
piece of software or an or equipment or
something like that right and what is
your experience sort of in in taking all
the knowledge that you gain from this
and make it sort of permanent for the
farmers and how do you deliver it should
it be through the public sector private
sector okay we have three models in our
mind one is the uh is the semi-automatic
model you can actually have these ofes
semi-automatic and there's actually
Services provided commercially by people
in Australia and probably here too who
will put out an experiment for you on
your machinery they will analyze the
results feed you back the results very
cheap sort of standard
thing there hardly been any taker in
that because there's no interpretation
of the result the second model is one
where you have a facilitated
interpretation of the results to create
knowledge and the knowledge is the more
permanent uh is the more perent entity
in that process and that's that's the
bit that we're trying to uh focus on
knowledge is much more permanent and
communicable than just individual
results and individual results often
Farmers aren't that Keen in those
results actually being distributed
widely anyway they'll they'll they're
happy to share them within their group
the third type of of is actually one
which we call a research-based where
you're just looking for that
generalizable result that's actually
done in field and that can be uh that
can be distributed Ed much more widely
but the result is is more General and
less useful to individual Farmers so
that I hope that answers your question
but basically what I'm saying is the
knowledge is a much more durable uh IP
and value entity than either individual
uh results
uninterpreted or in some cases the
research type of result it's the it's
the knowledge and the distribution of
the knowledge which seems to have
particular value to
and that can be spread but partially the
technique can be spread anywhere but the
the individual results you have to be
more careful actually Distributing
those this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at
cornell.edu